what's going on guys this is Rob and
Marvel's greatest villain returns and
the ending of the story is insane okay
check this out so this opens up
initially with Captain kcoa now for
those of you guys who are getting caught
up yes in the main fall of X event
mutants are being hunted all that kind
of stuff and you have the main fall of X
story going on Captain kcoa was at one
point Cyclops we know it's not Cyclops
because of the main fall of X event but
someone else's dress as his character
and he's basically leading a kind of
Gorilla War Warfare strategy against the
human population by any means necessary
mentality right do whatever you have to
do take out Humanity it doesn't matter
and so what he does as he's talking to
like the rest of his team right the
mutant Liberation Front is he literally
says you all have your orders if I don't
rendevu with you it's because I was
killed taking out oris's space station
it's been an honor to serve with you all
of course orcus being the organization
that's attacking the mutant population
in Fall of X right now and so what ends
up happening is that as he takes off
he's met by Dr stasis now we don't have
to go into like the whole history of Dr
stasis it's really convoluted and really
complicated suffice it to say Dr stasis
is basically one of the guys at orcus
that brought this guy back whoever it is
that he is and we will find out at the
end of the comic because it's insane so
the thing about this is while they're
having this conversation the questions
asked of Captain gcoa like why do you
need a nuke and his response is
insurance and so ends up happening is Dr
stasis reveals that he's been contacted
by Ben urick now Ben yuck's a reporter
in Marvel Comics and he's like NOS to
the ground hardcore during Marvel's
Civil War event back in the mid 2000s
him and Sally Floyd I think were her
name they launched like Frontline and
they were just like telling the whole
story of Civil War from like the
perspective of like the average person
it was an amazing tie in to that comic
and he's been one of my favorite
characters ever since but he's basically
been digging around to see whether or
not orcus is lying in saying that like
the mutant population attacked first
which is why orcus and their forces
launched their attack against the
mutants on the island of kakoa kicking
off the whole fall of X event we know
that's not true right we know that like
Humanity attacked first but the fact
remains here that Captain America and
his Unity Squad basically end up
arriving at the main base of operations
for the mutant Liberation Front after
Captain kcoa is already taken off and
once they get here of course at that
point it's a matter of subduing
everybody who's here and then finding
out why it is that Captain ccoa is
looking for a nuclear weapon because as
we covered in the last video they
already know that he's looking for one
and likely already has one and so at
that point you essentially have Wildside
who takes out black widow which is kind
of funny because one of the powers of
Wildside at least in this day and age is
he has the ability to force you to
relive your worst memories none of it
matters because for Black Widow right
for Natasha she's seen much worse than
this and she's learned how to kind of
like overcome her past so at this point
it's just reliving arbitrary memories
and that's it but of course you end up
having the rest of the team that take
out like the Von strucker twins we know
that Captain kakoa was just like taking
it to the Von strucker sister right like
we know that from the last video we saw
that coming from a mile away but they
ultimately end up going after Dukes now
here's the thing blob is one of these
characters in Marvel Comics where he is
criminally overlooked but he is a great
character not just in terms of like
strength but like his whole character
history and stuff like that but this
guy's very very hard to take out and if
I'm being honest with you guys I don't
remember whether or not it ever actually
happened in Marvel Comics but a fight
between the blob and the Hulk would
actually be a pretty credible fight and
I imagine that Dukes could probably hold
his own against the Hulk not forever but
for a pretty good chunk of ton but the
thing about this is that once all these
guys are taken out right that's when the
Von strucker twins join together and use
their powers the the reason why is
because they're kind of like the Wonder
Twins from DC Comics right like they
have to be holding hands or something
like that in order for their powers to
activate so basically sysock comes in
and does the most logical thing and just
cuts their hands off then they can't
touch then they can't use their powers
and it's pretty gruesome right because
like there's a point where Quicksilver
is like I mean you can use your
telepathic powers to like keep them from
feeling pain right and her response is
like I mean I could but like I'm not
going to and just like lets them suffer
in agony and so that's when they finally
get Dukes to their side and that's when
you end up finding out that there is
this great big huge kind of rally that's
taking place at Empire State University
where Dr stasis is going to be speaking
and what's intended here for Captain
ccoa is to plant this nuclear weapon
under the entirety of Empire State
University's uh Amphitheater and that in
effect he's going to go after the orcus
space station the nuclear weapon is
there as insurance because if Dr stasis
warns orcus about what it is that c
kakoa is doing he'll detonate the nuke
and Dr stasis will be killed and like
all those normal people will be killed
but because there's no mutants there and
because there's no one like Dr stasis to
spin the narrative and saying that like
mutants did it then ultimately it would
come out that like it was an attack by
orcus on humanity and orcus have been
the bad guys the entire time so
ultimately Dr stasis basically plays
ball the kicker about all this is that
even once the unity Squad gets to where
the nuclear weapon is
they can't simply just remove it right I
mean it's one of the first things you
would ask right can't someone like quips
or like Rogue with her enhanced strength
can't you just like pick it up and just
take it somewhere else the cool thing
about this is that it's booby trapped if
they move it it goes off it's a very
smart maneuver on behalf of like kcoa
and so what you do is you switch over to
Ben uich right and Ben yuck is basically
attacked by ccoa and simply saying that
like this article that you're about to
publish is never going to see the light
of day and he goes to take this guy out
now Captain America arrives on the scene
right then Captain America in turn
attacks C kcoa and this is kind of like
the fight we've all been waiting for
because the big question in uncanny
Avengers is who is Captain kakoa what in
the world's going on with this guy dude
I can't wait for this reveal so here's
the thing man this fight between the two
is like knock down drag out hardcore
right like literally Captain America
says like this is your only chance Stand
Down the response of kakoa not even your
pet telepaths could pry that information
from me you'll just have to poke at it
right for the most part he's just
taunting Steve Rogers he doesn't take
him seriously and he even says like what
a disgrace killing you would be a mercy
I don't intend to give this country and
that's where Captain America freaks out
because he knows who this guy is and
he's like don't you dare judge me and
don't you pass judgment over me or my
countrymen you're a traitor this is the
first clue Kendrick kakoa says I'm not
referring to the Past right I'm not
reliving the past I'm going to smash
what doesn't work and reforge this
broken World we've heard that before
we've heard that before right and then
like you have this moment with Deadpool
right where like once Captain mcoa takes
out all the forces of The Uncanny
Avengers he just like takes Captain
America's shield and throws it at
Deadpool and cuts him in half and
Deadpool is like okay so like be right
back cuz he's got to go heal right and
so that's the crazy thing it's Captain
America says I don't want to believe it
how how are you alive and that's when
Captain kakoa says nice hand Steve and
he says yeah here I am hail and Hardy
your Hydra Ray counterpart Steve Rogers
and what can I say my friend missed me
the ethnos state of ccoa brought you
back after your recent demise and
Humanity resurrected me to stop you from
helping them so here's the thing why
does this matter in Marvel Comics there
was a story called secret Empire and in
this story The Red Skull technically was
part of Avengers standstill but still
Red Skull ended up using a Cosmic Cube
to rewrite the entire history of Captain
America's past to turn him into a Hydra
agent so during secret Empire Captain
America with no one realizing he was a
Hydra agent the whole time had basically
taken out the entirety of the superhero
community in the United States and then
expanded beyond that and conquered
pretty much all of North America with
his sight set on the world he was the
greatest villain that Marvel ever had it
was amazing with that being said guys
we're going to bring this to an end if
you want to get caught up on secret
Empire and learn more about Hydra cap
click this link and if you want to get
caught up on fall of X click this one I
will catch you all later peace